well I've got all those spider-man
reviews under my belt now I can talk
about something new it's a cartoon
that's 19 years old I like talking about
older things but talk about something
that came out last week I'll get swept
away in the endless stream of Internet
people all ranting and raving about the
same subject how about something no one
else is talking about I also got you
guys guessing on which thing I'd review
next in that spider-man ps4 video and
the winner was Evo prendre thanks for
having a name that's easy to say guy I
thought saying the year it came out
would be a dead giveaway but it took a
little while this shows from a year
before I was born the Nightwatch
animated serie the spawn animated series
came out in a time when cartoons were
allowed to be dark gritty and aimed at
adults without being anime it was a
strange and spooky time I can only think
of one or two other series that compare
this to but I'll bring those up another
time now I want to preface this whole
review saying I don't think the spawn
comic is all that great or at least the
issues I've read Todd McFarlane's an
incredibly talented artist but his
writing is very
in the first issues spawn as a character
is like throwing deadpool Ghost Rider
and Prowler into a blender you might
raise an eyebrow at the third comparison
but Todd Drew Prowler first and the
similarities are uncanny just swap some
colors around as of this review I'm
still plowing through issues from the
90s and I hope to see even McFarland's
riding improved with time but who knows
how long that'll take if it happens at
all your spawn successful yeah is it a
successful of star wars nope as for the
animated series it's actually quite
different from the book it's about
completely different themes and almost
fits into a completely different genre
it was released on HBO so it had a
higher budget than most cartoons at the
time and basically no restraints they
pretty much showed whatever they felt
like be it extreme violence or cartoon
nudity or this guy's face HBO didn't
give a [ __ ] coincidentally they still
don't it's pretty much the only channel
that would be insane enough to
greenlight [ __ ] this dark do I mean
figuratively or literally maybe both the
story centers around an man named Al
Simmons a war hero slash mercenary slash
person who used guns who dies and is
resurrected through mysterious means he
doesn't know how he came back at first
or what he did to obtain a completely
new body but he's anything but human in
five years have passed since he did now
without a family friends in a face he
takes refuge in a maze of alleyways in
Harlem New York where he spends all of
his time scaring these poor homeless
people and mutilating anyone who even
mildly annoys him the majority of the
story takes focus away from his origins
and powers and looks at more realistic
scenarios like this crime boss who has
his influence spread across a lot of the
political world and his pulling strings
to make himself more powerful until one
day his whole operation starts to
unravel because someone or something is
killing his associates and stealing
weapons from him can you guess what it
is a lot of the human characters are
locked in political red tape government
cover-ups crime investigations and
assassination attempts it's a show that
captures a lot of the ugly side of
humanity between the politicians that
cults the criminals the wars and the few
decent people who get caught up in all
of it it may start to sound like an
animated House of
cards after a while did I mention that
there's a [ __ ] ghost in this too and
that he's the main character the plot is
so based in reality that the weird
supervillain characters that spawn
interacts with feel like an afterthought
uh he is apparently a cyborg you'll
almost get to the point where police
investigation of a child killer who
turns out to be a senator's illegitimate
son that he's hiding in order to save
his bid for the presidency is more
interesting than demon guy fights a
cyborg with rocket launchers in a dirty
alley
I guess spawn is less of a main
character and more of an entity in the
plot though he does have some
personality that shines through on rare
occasions listen fat boy I've had just a
mother enough anyway
spawn is constantly hounded by a
mysterious homeless man named Colt cog
could caught yeah they called me Colio
stroll yeah what he said who encourages
him to do the right thing and keep
himself from letting the influence of
the devil affect him would you know the
devil if you saw him did you know his
face his eyes I'm Todd McFarlane on the
flip side a demon from hell called the
clown or the violator or something also
follow spawn around and actively creates
conflict to make spawn stronger and push
him into making bad decisions in the
comics the clown is super obnoxious and
trying way too hard to be funny he
relies a lot on this running joke where
he goes on rants about ultra excessive
ways he's going to kill people but then
tears their heart out calls it a day
well as in the show he's more of just a
creepy creepy disturbing horrible
monster
that seems to have some of the most
memorable voice acting in the show you
asked us that wasn't in the goddamn
script I don't think you realize what's
a fake yeah he always sounds like he's
having so much fun being evil as sin
yeah you need a selfie you know you made
a [ __ ] deal
however Keith David turns in one of his
best vocal performances ever as spawn
he says everything with such intensity
your worst [ __ ] you're about two
seconds from wearing that smile around
us when he plays a character like
Goliath and gargoyles from around the
same time he sounds sort of sullen and
thoughtful here he sounds like a
pissed-off monster and eternal agony and
his occasional witty comments make them
all the more loveable as the depressed
hobo ghost Stefan is dead no
his voice is what makes the show any
other actor would have sounded soul
bland in this part which reminds me he
does a great job despite often not
having much to bounce off of the other
characters voices are sort of all over
the place some sounds so cartoonish that
it's hard to take them seriously you
know ex-cia killer turned ruthless
mercenary little more than a skeleton on
a respirator for almost three years I
mean please
but others sound very dramatic and
realistic with this solid a case against
Kyle the best I can do is try to keep
them off death row
90% of the time though everyone is
usually speaking in a very calm and dry
manner you watch this show with
headphones this guy's voice sounds like
ASMR I could fall asleep to the sound of
this guy mumbling about forged documents
regarding military hardware shipments it
looks like someone might be diverting
weapons shipments to other delivery
sites then changing the info in the
computer now running the numbers on tow
missiles Israel Kuwait database
confirmation of serial numbers Orton
shipped and received let's see the
suddenly came verifying
cross-referencing total positioning no
signal no position given she says those
missiles never arrived I also think they
stole a piece of this shows music and
remixed it for the twisted metal black
soundtrack
the animation for every season is very
impressive some of the best I've ever
seen out of a TV show you could tell a
lot of time and care was put into every
little scene everything looks so
gorgeously dark I once made a joke with
a friend about the 60 spider-man cartoon
it said that you could take any frame of
that show with spider-man in it and make
it into a meme well this show you can
take any still frame with spawn and make
it into a heavy metal album cover the
animation for his cape is so fluid and
smooth and the character designs are
reasonably sophisticated for something
that has to be in motion so often this
must have been a pain in the ass to draw
thanks Korea you put in the work so we
don't have to the lighting is so
stylized and dark that it covers some of
the same ground as Batman the Animated
Series where some of the scenes are so
shadowy you can see specks of dust that
were on the animation cell when they put
this together I love fun little details
like that makes everything feel more
authentic you don't get charming little
blemishes like that in the era of
digital animation instead you get shows
like total drama island or Family Guy
where everything is the same character
design shown in the same position from
the same camera angle with maybe two
types of lighting man I don't want to
sound like that guy but something was
lost when we started using computers for
everything it all looks so much lazier
even the action cartoons
hey this character Angela becomes a
member of the guardians of the galaxy
later for some reason weird right
each season does something sort of
different with the visuals season one
has character designs almost made out of
the shadows and light they don't often
have color and are more constructed by
the differences of the lighting in the
area around them there may be times when
there are no more than two colors on the
screen at once which is contrasted by
sequences in daytime where everything is
crystal clear season 2 has more of an
anime approach where the character
designs stay the same colors but are
shadowed in a more traditional way it
also often has this hazy blue
glow that I feel like all darker
cartoons from the 90s had the
backgrounds are far more detailed and
grungy and the animation on the
characters just a little bit choppier
season 3 seems to be a sort of hybrid of
the two styles depending on the tone of
the situation regardless of which season
those spawn is drawn the same almost
throughout go to allow looks pretty
normal in the first few minutes of the
show but after that you really see him
anymore in good lighting he spent so
much time a hidden in shadows that you'd
be forgiven to think he was just a
silhouette with a cape they leave him
pitch-black throughout the entire second
and third season keep in mind he's
supposed to look like this it's like
some animation team absolutely refused
to draw him in any more detail than that
well you want us to have red black and
white on the screen all at once or are
you crazy
you know cool that would look now I just
draw an outline with eyes and we're done
can I say the best shots in HBO are the
ones where spawn is 90% black a little
bit of red [ __ ] him you see the eyes
his head black his cloak cloak his back
he's standing in front of something
black and you pull back and you just
barely see him in a shat like when I
when I get those I just go home there it
is be still my heart cuz I lay down the
law no arms no legs no chat like I did
he is a head and a cape oh-oh-oh
yeah okay it was his fault I'd say this
is the best telling of the storyline
being that it wasn't that god-awful 90's
movie the special effects movie event of
the year on what planet are you hi did
you see the movie before you wrote that
whoever you are there are little things
that they leave out from the books to
stabilize the tone like spawn having the
power to transform into some doofy
looking white guy so he can have stilted
dialogue with Wanda and her new husband
if I wanted to see a nerdy white guy
have awkward conversations with women I
just strap a mirror to my face leave
that [ __ ] out so if you want to get to
know spawn but need a filter for the
horrific 90s version of the story head
on over here
we also have a Rob Liefeld character in
here
but he's a lot less cheesy except for
that time he has a flashback to the war
midway through the coitus and starts
screaming and crying that's probably the
only really unintentionally funny moment
in the whole series the rest is fine but
but this scene is just yeah the series
pretty much resolved its main storylines
but it never continued any further than
that and leaves on a pretty rough
cliffhanger let that little mystery keep
you up at night but I guess that's what
the comics are for right so if you want
to know what happens next you may have
to stomach some of Todd McFarlane's if
he ability to tell a story the book
looks awesome but the details needed
some ironing don't think I hate Todd or
anything just because I criticized his
dialogue and scene structure in fact I
should probably bring up a fun story to
clear the air so my dad has been a lover
of comics since he was a kid growing up
in the 70s and he has two copies of the
first issue of spawn which he's been a
fan of since the day it hit shelves well
once upon a time in 2013 Todd McFarlane
was doing a book signing at some [ __ ]
place I don't know and it was one of the
worst days ever we got there two hours
early and the place told everyone to
grab different colored tickets our group
got the orange tickets they said they
were serving the purple tickets first
then they got around to the red blue
tickets and ended on orange we walked
around this building for like five hours
waiting for the signing and at the time
an unrelated medical issue was causing
my dad to bleed internally the whole
time so by the end of the night he
looked like a zombie when MacFarlane
finally did signed the book he handed it
to my dad who has a cane mind you in a
stack with another book so the one on
the bottom being the issue number one
had the cover smudged rendering all that
time away stead passed out from blood
loss two days later now I'm not gonna
say it's Todd's fault because that's
absurd but it's a [ __ ] movie
I also learned a lot about Todd
personally that day he went up on stage
before the signing and talked about his
career and imparted some advice like for
example if your boss tells you to do
something
blindly say yes to it then do whatever
you want to do instead all the change I
wanted to make on Spider Man they were
like no no no no no and then I just went
screw it and I'd ignored them anyways
and I did it the sales went up to the
point that when I left the new kid
coming in you guys draw like a Todd guy
so if you ever wonder why suddenly
spider-man's webs went from being a
straight line to crazy squiggles that go
all over the place it's because of
Todd's flawless logic that led him to
being a millionaire also he kind of
looks like Matthew McConaughey there
wasn't a point to that whole story I
just thought it would be fun to tell it
shut up it's my video now this series is
a hidden gem for me people always talk
about how great comic shows were in the
90s but they always leave this one out
it's all about Batman and x-men and
spider-man and even Superman those were
all fantastic certainly better than some
of the crap we all on now but I just
want to point out that they weren't the
only ones worth watching back then so
let's start bugging Netflix and Hulu to
stream this or better yet have another
DVD release or wait the whole thing's on
YouTube so just watch it there for free
well Todd won't get royalties to keep
buying more baseball hats but you'll get
to see this great show so I guess it's a
win-win get out there and do it he was
rude only got two seconds he cost me 20
bucks that's you know it's like Anderson
prefers to let his fists do the talking
back
before I permanently introduce your face
to your colon